let's talk a little bit about marijuana
Hillary Clinton and Chelsea Clinton
Hillary Clinton's daughter Chelsea
Clinton made a pretty disturbing
assertion about the health risks of
marijuana during a campaign event in
ohio on saturday she showed up in uh
ohio and said you know we really need to
be careful around marijuana because
there are deaths that could be
attributed directly or indirectly to
marijuana i'm going to play the video
for you and i have a lot to say about
this take a look but we also have
anecdotal evidence now from colorado
where some of the people who were taking
uh marijuana for those purposes um the
coroner believes after they died there
was drug interactions with other things
they were taking I want to be super
clear here okay yes smoking anything is
bad for your lungs right whether it's
marijuana or cigarettes or banana leaves
or durian right whatever it is that you
start lighting up and smoking that can
be bad for your lungs there is no doubt
about it and yes Chelsea Clinton is not
saying that marijuana alone killed
someone but that for some people using
medical marijuana and other drugs that
it's possible anecdotally that maybe the
interaction between the medical
marijuana and other medications could
have been what killed someone not the
marijuana alone itself there are
basically two major problems with this
claim and this has been covered pretty
extensively by a number of websites
including marijuana dot-com number one
as far as a marijuana overdose that is
fatal there has never been a single
documented case of that that's number
one okay that includes deaths from
interactions between marijuana
consumption and other drugs uh but
number two the second problem is she
admits that this is anecdotal and that's
really one of the problems that were
having Hillary Clinton's position on
this issue is well she's open to
changing the laws around marijuana but
she wants more research but the current
laws we have make it difficult to do
that research and thus we end up with
people like Chelsea Clinton saying you
know anecdotally
here's something that may have possibly
been considered to have possibly
happened and then it just gets
perpetrated and it gets uh wound up and
spit back out time and time again and
part of the problem is that there's this
vicious circle where Hillary Clinton is
open to changing the law if we have
better research about what would happen
but the law as it is will prevent us
from having more research and of course
this ignores the fact that there
actually is already in spite of the fact
that it is difficult to do research on
the medical benefits of of cannabis of
marijuana uh we actually do have many
studies that tell us there are
significant benefits so you know the the
the line that many people are coming up
with in response to this is well Hillary
Clinton has big pharma donors and
there's a very significant interest in
keeping marijuana illegal at the federal
level and that's what this is all about
I don't know Rachel if that truly is
what this is about but what I do know is
that when you start opening up the door
to what Chelsea Clinton is admitting is
completely anecdotal instances you're
not really doing anything positive for
anybody you just spreading anecdotal
misinformation right that's kind of
puzzling but also I think with uh with
Hillary she needs to support marijuana
in order to gain the vote of Millennials
so this whole thing seems kind of
puzzling to me because that's an area
that she's struggled with so I'm not
really sure then where any of this is
coming from particularly if you believe
that the gary johnson support the
libertarian support which tends to be
very very uh liberal open on issues of
drug legalization if you are targeting
that group millennial libertarian minded
socially liberal individuals in swing
states which hillary clinton should be
targeting she should be valuate valuing
that uh group of the electorate then uh
this is probably not a good path to go
down but needless to say chelsea clinton
showing up and I don't believe doing
Hillary Clinton any favors with the
science-based community there are
probably some groups that hear this and
they say that's right we gotta be tough
on this but with the science-based
community I don't see what you are
gaining with this we will take a break
next we will talk to attorney Mike
Papantonio about his great new book